oh the beautiful Los Angeles River if
anyone's ever wondered what it looks
like beautiful lush
[Music]
and then that happened flakes you doing
average oh yeah yeah and they're gonna
make it right the next life okay
you look great oh I just hoping that all
of this gets back to the house I'm
thinking and you look really capable
right now I'm doing
okay kid we can't be sorry good morning
it's one of these morning's last night
in the dark i spray-painted my new
elephant that I got so we're gonna go
check it out
oh you need some work new buddy hey
paddy why does this look like this
oh you're drunk I put my hair in a bun
like that because then tricking people
into thinking I'm together lifehack oh
hello again I just got done a meeting
with represent which is the company that
I just did
the limited edition its grace t-shirts
through that you guys bought like
maniacs being a really great creative
meeting to discuss the next a piece of
merch that I want to make available for
you guys it's gonna be really cool I
want to create merge that isn't grace
Helbig specific that it's just clothes
that you would like if you didn't know
who I was do you guys like Raglan's and
or do you like hoodless sweatshirts cool
good talk I'm videoing video run Lance's
dirty pop show it's really exciting
double teams right now yes I'm sorry
there's very pensive very threatening
[Music]
I'm at The Frisky award show got a
housewarming gift from my mom today so
yummy this it's a wind chime with
butterflies onyx my mom sincerely loves
butterflies I think she thinks that
she's a human butterfly and then I got a
really sweet note from her I'm not gonna
read it to you because it's just for me
now you know that my mom fully supports
100 flowers
[Music]
in a car heading to the airport I know
if I was quite long enough you would
take over and handle this huh yeah
someone that this lion come to
Washington DC for their special meeting
7 a.m. right now get ready to go to a
very special meeting I came up here last
minute there are Tigers oh my god I hate
everything to make this great tigers
bears joke
in addition to me being a lion I know
life just sucks okay
back in the hotel room slightly left
lioness than before ha today's been a
really crazy day I got to go to the
White House with a bunch of other
youtubers here are some videos
[Music]
and I got to watch an event for a new
initiative that the White House is doing
called it's on us dot org it's all about
preventing sexual harassment I got to
see Vice President Biden and President
of the United States Barack Obama speak
and I was two rows back while they spoke
it was really very surreal a young girls
I think my age spoke before Joe Biden
and she was raped when she was a
freshman in college and she talked all
about how getting into college is hard
and getting back your college experience
is extremely hard after you've had an
experience of sexual harassment it was
really really moving they launched the
campaign today and I wanted to mention
it to you guys because I think that it
is so important the whole I guess
message of the campaign is that it's on
all of us as a community to prevent
sexual harassment it's on us as adults
to teach children mostly males that
their masculinity is not these old very
wrong standard boys used to be taught
that they're dangerous and the girls
used to be taught that boys are
dangerous that's crazy we're all human
beings is what we need to be taught and
a certain level of respect among humans
as humans is is the only thing that
matters there's absolutely no no time or
place or reason for why a man should
ever raise his hand or harass a woman
ever or a man for that matter because
this happens to men too I've had one of
those days that came up out of nowhere
and wasn't totally for what exactly it
was and have been totally influenced and
empowered by everyone that spoke today
and everything that happened today if
you feel so inclined go to it's on us
org and you can take the pledge on us
too
teach youth what it means to be a human
in the world and not what it means to
take advantage of humans in the world
this might not be the last time that I
talk about this because I feel really oh
I feel like I just want everyone to be
nice what a day whoo okay I'm gonna take
a nap I don't know stop you're still
recording yeah